Hey whats up guys today i'm hanging out with my friend Zack
From a channel called JerryRigEverthing. He has no idea what we are getting up to today do you?
I have no idea I know that you have been recently been involved with a lot of like organs
like biological organs
so I think it's something along those lines
and i'm kind of nervous about it to be honest
yeah  he has every reason to be nervous
because today we are going to be tasting brains
That is a terrible plan.
You guys remember in the previous video we took cow brains
cast them in silicone
and then we cleaned those molds out and we cast gummy
and poured the gummy inside the mold
so its been about 24 hours
they have been sitting in the fridge
it's time to take those out
reveal what we've created
and give them a taste test.
Oh boy!
so lets do that now Zack go to the fridge
there is two little molds in there.
These ones in the green.
Yeah so we got these little yeah bluish green molds here.
Oh there heavy!
You thought they were going to be real brains didn't you.
Yeah.
I was not excited about that.
Cool why don't you go ahead and just throw it down there on the counter.
So I got my assistant Zack here all gloved up
we are going to peel off the tape and very very slowly open these thing up and see how they turned out
So, what we're going to do now is just slowly peel the gummy back
You can probably leave that intact for now
And what I want you to do is start pulling at the pulling at the edges very gently
this is gummy and its sticking it will release from the silicon
if he goes slow enough.
Am i going to tear the silicone at all or is it going to come lose
silicon will be fine it's the gummy that
were worried about it is very very
slowly very very we are going to see if we can get those
things out intact
that's in there that's right made
different decisions here so that when
the gummy set we can pull it open
and exposed the whole thing and we don't
want the brains anywhere LOL only good
no brainy leakage
I'll hold that down
anyway you can see some of the bubbles
actually came up to the base of the
brain but it looks like the tops
probably going to be fully intact
looks like the green is more at the
bottom right now the green color tool is
actually pulling away very nicely
silicon is actually a lot more sturdy
than you think it would be like it's
really strong holding together very
tightly
yeah like you're using my both arms very
strongly to hold we have it would hold
the most
go ahead and grab it put that thing over
and let's take a look
we have success
oh my goodness look at that is crazy
that is awesome
look at the detail that worked out
really well it's even got the gap
between the left and right side of the
brain
you can even pull that apart look down
inside a little bit gently
we are severing connections to get right in there with
our surgical equipment
very cool very cool wow that's amazing
it actually worked the check this out
guys
this turned out almost an exact clone
exact replica of the brain that we had
and what's really cool is you do get the
slimy green texture on the top two and
then it's like this gross purple
underneath
I think we have a successful zombie
brain casting what you think it looks
good this looks a lot tasty than the
other brains out thinking about ya so
moment of truth guys how does a gummy
zombie brain taste
well we're about to find out or more
particularly actually Zack's about to find out all right
we got a guinea pig we got our
gummy brain let's go just I want
you to take a giant bite out of that let
and let me know what you think
ok so just clarified this is in the same
mold that the real brain sat in right
that is correct
okay just checking oh wow that was a
good bit it was a healthy size bit I'm
impressed
so what do you think it tastes like gummy
so that's good that is good it doesn't
taste like brains not that I've ever
had brains
it's pretty good good to hear so there
we have it no aftertaste no residual
taste of brains we just got the full
tummy effect we got the purple we got
the green we got everything cool going
on here so I'm calling out of success
i'm excited to see what's in this one
looks open that up next
alright let's take a look look at how
well these seams fit back together
this part is looking a little bit tricky
we're gonna have to approach this
gingerly just want to reiterate that this
rubber the silicone stuff is a lot
stronger than you think it like it is it
requires a lot of force to keep it open
it's a good workout yeah there you go I
just felt the release and here is our
brain reveal nice that captured a lot of
detail it's amazing the details of that
captures checked out brains
goomy goomy brain drain bump let's put
our minds together with your brains
Squishy Brains
I guess it only be right if i did a taste
test as well would it not where to start that
is the question where to start i think
im just gonna take a nice big bite right
out the back right here
it has got a fun texture
umm yep thats gummy one hundred percent genuine
homemade gummy
that's what i call brain candy food for
thought
cool look at the different patterns here
you can see where the green splits and
turns into purple i love the way that
green glows their their king of random
approved so what I want you to do is I
want to grab that thing and just slowly
pull it off I want you to dissect our gummy
brain here grab onto this thing down
here and just slowly pull it apart look
inside there
look at wow you know what's amazing
about this is that's about how soft the
actual brain could literally do that to
a real brain that's crazy it just
tears right apart but it's still like
a little bit stronger than you think it
is I mean it's like literally pulling
apart of gummy worm just way thicker  so
we've got our epic gummy zombie brains
are working out great
we've taken a bite I think it's time to
have a little fun I don't have anymore
kitchen knives because I destroyed them
all but I do have a propane torch and a
butter knife that may be fun to just heat this thing up
thing up and glided through the center
of the brain like a gummy lobotomies
were performing right now I think so
that's getting hot there we go alright guys
check it out we got a glowing knife to
we have a brain here I want you to glide it
right through the middle there haha
sizzle what nice effortless look at that that is beautiful
and it smells terrible like burning
gummy let's get another one all that
still hot oh hear that its like dripping
you think if I held it together would
like actually fuse back together
look at that
oh yeah out of the clean-cut dude of the
clean-cut you got a nice cross-section
you can see the purple and the green on
both sides delicious so hot knife vs.
gummy brain I'd call that a success we got this
this little weird piece down here i
think im just gonna torch that with a
blowtorch
let's just melted
woah thats awesome
like a marshmallow
yeah it is
oh wow oh my gosh it is like a
marshmallow exactly like a marshmallow
you like that layer of carbon look at
how smooth and shiny is on the inside
lick it i was joking but that's going to
do it do it do it
that tastes great tastes cool
smooth clean gummy say that again
i love that
that looks really neat. I am going to have to see that in slow mo
there it is
that whole thing turned into a
crust that flowed down solidified but then you
get this clean little gummy in the
middle there
there we go so we have reduced our
gummy to this beautiful little
nugget which i'm going to eat right now
I've got a little crush the carbon her
it's the same taste when you burn your
marshmallows over the campfire but what
I love about the brain here look how
shiny that is like cutting through with
a hot knife you get this drippy shiny
gooey sorry Zack i know that was your piece
no its alright i'm willing to share so I still
got this for pound gummy brain from that
19 that we cast I think it's time to
pull this out and just revealed the
original gummy and what I would normally
do is fill this up with plaster that we
have a full cast we've used this is
asked in the cast a new gummy in but just for
the sakes were revealing everything
today we're just going to get everything
out on the table so it's like Christmas
Zach go crazy
let's just dig right in look at that now
even though this is paper you'll see
that once you kind of get loosened up it
should be fairly freely once we rip that
off everything also pop loose footloose
and this is how easy it is you just kill
this thing away comes out perfectly
intact and then we got a cool little
skin for it look at that okay that we try that one
yeah which one tastes better which one tastes
better yes thats cherry
okay no offense man but this one tastes better
can't argue with that there's a lot more
sugar in this one there's a lot more
my bite was bigger
this is your brain on drugs
smoking hot
oh thats really hot
alright we are going to push this little bit here
that guy's cool experiment today our
brains worked out perfectly of so
impressed that we got our tummies on the
brain looking feeling and tasting with
it i was very impressive detail of it i
didn't think that the mobile to capture
like all those little crevices inside
the brain that was intense and big
thanks to Zack for being the guinea pig
be willing to take the first bite I
would have taken by the real brains too
if you need to make you I'm here for you
i bet he would have
yep so Zack has a channel called jerry-rigged
everything if you remember back when I
did the stealth shelf project he
actually rebuilt that on his channel
using our kit so if you're trying to
build the stealth-shelf yourself you can
reference one of his videos he also does
a lot of cellphone repair tutorials and
all kinds of things completely unrelated
to eating brains more about using brain
so go check him out he's got an awesome
tech channel i'll put a link in the
description below thanks for joining us
today guys it's been awesome hanging out
with you we looking for in the next
video document the average cow brain
weighs about 1 pound and here's the
thing we did some fact-checking and
that's only about point one percent of
cows body weight in contrast of humans
our brains take up two percent of our
body weight but the largest brain in an
animal is sperm whale at a whopping
17 pounds that would be a whole lot of
gummy if we're to catch the sperm whale
brain here today